hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today we're going to talk about African
American vernacular English African
American vernacular English which you
may also hear referred to as Ebonics is
a group of dialects of English that
developed among African American
communities in the United States because
of the expressive and innovative nature
of these dialects they are very
influential and they are the source of
many slang expressions and idioms that
are used in general American English and
even international English yet despite
the fact that English speakers borrow
their favorite pieces of aave there's
still the persistent belief that its
speakers speak bad english or broken
english as though they're constantly
making mistakes when they speak but any
linguist will tell you that's not how
language works aave
is not broken standard english it's
simply not standard english it's
something else
enslaved African people were first
brought to what is now the United States
in 1619 and over the next two centuries
hundreds of thousands more were brought
over similar to the development of
english-based Creole languages in the
Caribbean aave developed from contact
between speakers of West African
languages and their english-speaking
slave masters as well as indentured
servants from Great Britain and Ireland
but while aave has some creole like
features it's much closer to standard
English than Caribbean Creoles are one
theory suggests that it arose as a
result of the slaves learning the
dialectal English spoken by the
indentured servants who were poor and
oftentimes not proficient in standard
English another theory suggests that it
developed as a creole language but then
converged with Standard English through
a process of decree ol ization the more
accepted theory is the first one but
there was probably also some creole
influence from the slaves brought to the
u.s. from the caribbean with black
americans living as a largely separate
community first under slavery than under
segregation it makes sense that they
would develop their own enduring
dialects and it also makes sense that
they would develop their own in-group
expressions and idioms that were
difficult for hostile outsiders to
understand the great northward migration
of the twentieth century helped
establish a VE as an enduring dialect
group throughout the country first off
let me be clear that not all African
Americans speak aave
and there are some people who do speak
it who aren't African American and as is
typically the case with non-standard
varieties of a language aave
exists on a continuum with standard
English and people mix the two of them
to varying degrees depending on the
situation their socioeconomic status and
their perception of the dialect and it's
also true that there's variation within
aave
based on region and generation but I'll
describe some typical features that are
unquestionably a part of aave people
often associate aave with its slang
especially words and expressions that
have crossed over into other varieties
of English often through music and other
media words like dis which is short for
disrespect beef meaning a conflict
squash meaning to put an end to
something cosign meaning to vouch for
someone give props meaning to give
praise or recognition to someone and
lots of other expressions like that but
this kind of slang is not representative
of aave slang by its very nature is
always changing the vast vast majority
of vocabulary is standard English
vocabulary even though sometimes words
are used slightly differently either in
form or in meaning the core of aave is
really its grammar and its phonology
let's examine its grammar verbs there
are a lot of little differences in how
verbs are used first is and are are
often left out she over da that's before
a phrase showing location he will funny
do that's before a noun phrase they
gotta crazy here it's left out before an
adjective
they're also left out before the present
progressive ing he don't know what he
talking about note that is and are are
the only forms of to be that are dropped
am is not left out and neither all the
past tense forms was and were more on
those later or be also isn't or can't be
dropped at the end of a sentence Oh what
it is the basic rule is that they can
only be dropped in aave in the same
contexts in which they can become
contractions in standard English
habitual B there are contexts in which
speakers of aave used B when is or are
would be used in standard English for
example we be working 24/7
B has a special purpose when used like
this it indicates habitual action this
sentence is also possible we work but
that just means working right now rather
than habitually working over an extended
period of time
another example he always be telling
people what to do
so you can see that the use of B is not
a random choice or mistake it's
systematic and it's grammatically
correct according to the rules of aave
there's also an intensive habitual
marker this is similar to habitual B but
is more emphatic he's they run away
forward this means that it happens
pretty much all the time it's habitual
there's also an intensified continuous
marker steady it shows that the action
is in progress but not necessarily
habitual over a longer period of time
you never listen I've been told you to
stop but you steady play for the word
plan here I would probably say playing
around or messing around
lack of person number agreement before
we saw this sentence he don't know what
he talking about this part he don't may
have stood out to you as different verb
conjugations are generally flattened so
that they are the same regardless of
person and number and they was acting
crazy
they was rather than they were in the
present tense
this usually means that the third person
singular form doesn't have an S yeah you
work at the shop down the street he work
rather than he works that's the basic
pattern most of the time a common
expression that seems to contradict this
rule is gods - okay you trevor
August's go notice the S on gods even
when it's not in the third person
singular gods - seems to have developed
as distinct from God ah both being
contractions of have got to gotsta is
more emphatic than God ah completive or
perfective done the word done is
frequently used as an aspect marker
showing that an action has been
completed you know you don't messed up
right this is often interpreted as
referring to an action completed in the
very recent past but that's not
necessarily the case
it could be further back in the past but
using done gives the feeling that the
situation after the action is
different than the situation before it
you don't woke up the whole neighbor the
word beam is also used with verbs in two
ways one way is called unstressed beam
it's used like half beam or has been in
standard English Shema made for a long
time
there's also stressed beam when beam
pronounced more like bin is stressed it
means that the action occurred a long
time ago or that the action or state has
been continuing for a long time she been
Mary
this means that she's been married for a
long time the stress on bin indicates
that the marriage began in the remote
past so the phrase for a long time is
unnecessary in fact when using stressed
beam it's actually ungrammatical to
include an adverbial phrase like that up
in finish my homework ma there are a few
special ways to express the future in
aave one way is using gone or gonna
which is a contraction of going to we go
visit them soon gonna is used in casual
speech and a lot of varieties of English
so this is no big surprise another more
distinctive feature form is finna I'm
finna go home this is a contraction of
fixin to which is frequently heard in
dialects of the southern US like I'm
fixin to go home often they hit the
dough in a circuit hit the dough or hit
the door
meaning leave there's also a special
form used in the first person singular
imma I'm away right here while you you
ready
imma developed as a contraction of I'm
gonna it may be a contraction of I'm
gonna but it's now used slightly
differently as a declaration of
immediate action whereas I'm gonna or
I'm gon is a little further into the
future
negation the negative in aave is
frequently expressed with ain't though
not in all contexts with a verb in the
simple present tense don't is used
rather than ain't he doesn't live here
anymore
he'll you know lo in the present
continuous ain't is used man I ain't
even tryna here are there this is like
saying I have no interest in hearing
what you're saying
notice that ain't often blends in with
the words around it I ain't is more like
I ain't I ain't even is more like I and
even man I ain't even tryna here are
there in the past tense it's used
I didn't say anything they say it's also
used with the present perfect I haven't
said anything they said nothing by the
way notice that there is a specific
difference in the verb tense between I
ain't say and I ain't said those aren't
random variations you might have also
noticed that anymore and anything are
replaced with their negative
counterparts resulting in a double
negative
actually both that and ain't appear in
other dialects of English as well and
aren't unique to aave but it does have a
unique kind of double negative or
sometimes triple negative construction
called negative inversion okay nobody's
saying like she can it's standard
English this would be nobody can sing
like she can't
ain't nobody go home till we finish
nobody's going home until we finish in
this construction the auxiliary verb
moves to the beginning of the sentence
and becomes negative possessives
possession in aave
tends to be shown by syntax with the
apostrophe s ending deleted for example
Yamada house
notice that the word dad has no
apostrophe s ending but it's clear that
dad is the one who possesses the house
because dad comes right before house in
the sentence for possessive adjectives
in the third-person subject pronouns are
used they was looking for a furnace
notice that they appears twice once as
the subject and again as the possessor
but again we know the second one is
possessive because it appears right
before the noun friends asked
constructions aave features several
interesting uses of the word ass first
it intensifies an adjective who's that
some random s ba this has been adopted
by speakers of other varieties of
English to some extent and even some
speakers of standard English use it in
casual settings when they want to be
more expressive it also reminds me of
something Australians and New Zealanders
say to intensify adjectives they might
say something like this beer is cheap as
not ass but as a second together with a
possessive it's used in place of a
pronoun but with a sense of urgency yo
as don't learn this means you're going
to learn but the subtext is that you're
chastising or warning someone the third
it can also be used as a reflexive in
place of self
get yo ass and Santos that just means
get yourself inside the house yo ass
replaces yourself this is used in other
varieties of English as well but in a
much more limited capacity pronunciation
African American vernacular English also
has a characteristic accent or rather a
range of accents that share some common
features we can't talk about all those
features here but let's look at a few of
them Arlis pronunciation hey ve
tends to be or less at the end of words
similar to the accents of England and
some North Eastern American accents
brother mother sister at least in some
varieties of aave when are appears after
Oh or you the are disappears and the
word ends in an O sound door becomes dou
floor becomes hello your becomes yo sure
becomes so some dipthongs become
monophthongs for example my ride becomes
bara ride refers to a car by the way in
standard English the vowel in my and
ride is a diphthong basically meaning
that the vowel shifts from one to
another within a single syllable I I in
aave it's just one continuous vowel
sound ah also my might be pronounced
with the schwa when it's unstressed in
rapid speech like ma changes in th
sounds in other words interdental
fricatives fuh in the the voiceless th
sound tha is sometimes replaced by fir
bath Bev south-south the way these th
sounds are rendered as fir reminds me of
some dialects spoken in England
voiceless tha sometimes becomes too
Horta this sound tah is a voiceless
dental stop which is somewhere between
two a T sound and tha the voiceless th
sound with might become weight and in
that sample you can hear the
globalization of the to sound it often
becomes a glottal stop just like T does
in general American English in certain
contexts like at the end of a word
voiced the sometimes becomes duh
or the this is a voiced Dental stop
you could say that it's somewhere
between a D sound and the voiced the
sound that might be dead
some consonants are silent this includes
the final consonant in some consonant
clusters for instance past is pronounced
pairs and hand becomes a to be clear
this happens in other accents as well
including mine but it tends to be more
consistent in aave
even in some contexts in which I would
pronounce the sound also initial
consonant sounds are sometimes dropped
in auxiliary verbs like don't and quasi
auxiliary verbs like gonna I don't know
becomes oh no this process probably also
resulted in the future form imma that we
saw before some words have different
stress which can actually undo the vowel
reduction of standard English in
standard English well at least in
general American English this word is
pronounced police in aave it's
pronounced police actually the man in
the recording stresses the second
syllable but it's often stressed on the
first syllable
and as with some other features of aave
this is also a feature of southern
speech in general so that's interesting
right in my accent the O is dropped or
at least reduced but an AAA ve the O is
clearly pronounced so when sounds are
dropped in a dialect like AAA ve is that
any different from me dropping certain
sounds when I speak the truth is that
the phonology of any spoken variety of
English is separate from English
spelling and every variety has somewhat
different phonological rules that its
speakers follow should speakers of aave
be encouraged to give up their dialect
in favor of standard English well keep
in mind that all over the world in
various different languages there are
dialects that people use in informal
situations while they learn the standard
language at school and use that in
formal situations including writing
there are dialects of German Japanese
Arabic and countless other languages and
people switch between dialectal speech
and standard speech depending on the
context you can make a good argument
that everyone in a society should learn
the standard language well in order to
increase their opportunities and to
improve communication between different
segments of society but there's nothing
that makes a dialect incorrect
if your intention is to speak that
dialect while speaking a dialect at a
job interrview might be incorrect in
that context speaking it with your
friends is
so standard English is clearly an
important tool but aave is not inferior
to it it's simply different from
standard English just as all dialects
are that includes the dialects of Great
Britain Ireland Australia and everywhere
else that English has spoken the
question of the day to speakers of
African American vernacular English to
what extent do you use it in daily life
and to what extent do you use standard
English and can you add any features of
aave that didn't appear in the video and
to others are there any words or
expressions you use that originally came
from aave
what are they leave your responses in
the comments down below
the man who recorded the audio samples
for this video
Laurence is an artist who creates
fantastic portraits like these and he
can create custom portraits of you too I
recommend you follow him on Instagram
and check out his work I also want to
give a big shout out to all the Lang
focused patreon supporters especially
the top-tier patrons whose names are on
the screen check out patreon.com/lenguin
the benefits of the various tiers and to
everyone thank you for watching and have
a nice stay
[Music]
[Music]